we're gonna switch gears here to a very
serious story out of Colorado there is
an intense search underway right now it
has turned up no sign of a missing
mother who disappeared on Mother's Day
authorities say that Suzanne more few
left for a bike ride near her home about
150 miles south of Denver and she never
came back
investigators searched her husband's job
site over the weekend molla lankey is
following this story mola
did they find anything significant well
police were hoping that a construction
site near more fuze home would lead to
some sort of break in the case but after
three days of searching they say no
clues were found so the investigation
continues another dead end in the search
for 49 year old suzanne Morphew a mother
of two police say she went on a bike
ride two weeks ago before disappearing
since Friday state county and local
investigators were sifting through this
construction site just east of her home
looking for clues the property's owner
said Suzanne's husband Barry had
previously been hired to lay dirt on the
site but according to the Chaffee County
Sheriff's Office several locations at
the construction site were searched they
were unable to make any connection to
Suzanne more fuze case at this time
adding that the property owner was
cooperative and not connected to her
disappearance Suzanne if anyone is out
there that can hear this that has you
please the search at the construction
site comes a week after this emotional
plea from Suzanne's husband a volunteer
firefighter the family says he was out
of town in Denver the day she
disappeared a neighbor reported her
missing on Mother's Day police recovered
more fuse bike the day she vanished but
they would not say what condition it was
in days later officials found a personal
item of hers but did not specify what it
was it's a mystery that has shaken more
fuse neighborhood super septa Minister I
was small community you know they she
ate at our restaurant all the time now
more fuze family and friends are
offering a two hundred thousand dollar
reward for any tips that lead to her
whereabouts
in a
an interview with our Denver station
Casey NC her nephew Trevor said they're
doing everything they can to get answers
we have a team a force of people working
on their computers and on social media
consolidating all the information we
find officials are asking more fuze
neighbors to hold on to any surveillance
video they might have for Mother's Day
weekend the weekend that she disappeared
just in case they might need it
Dale they also say that hundreds of tips
have come into their offices very
upsetting story molla let's hope they
have a happy ending there thank you so
much